your club Danny cows huh okay we're
podcasting uh so we thought we would
want to talk about college today yeah
cuz you just graduated in the spring and
we're approaching fall time and that's
the worst time because that's when your
summers over and you go back to school
boo
just kidding well you just graduated in
the spring yeah your diplomas on the
wall who are see you
it looks dope thank you how does it feel
knowing that you're not going back to
school ever again and like not in the
fall feels good
well let me put it this way
I'm gonna walk you through it I was
talking about brother who is going back
to school I have a key Marlon he's going
back he's actually going to Chapman for
a second year but I was talking to him
and he was like yeah I'm going on a trip
and then school starts I'm like ah I
totally didn't even think of that like
it hasn't even crossed once I walked the
stage I had like checked off something
my mind where I was like this is never
going to be a concern again so when I
talked to my brother and he was like you
know I gotta go back to school I was
like totally forgot about that suck
institution about having to count down
the days and feel that shitty feeling
and it's done I'm sure I'll get it
elsewhere now but I'm done with school
but we did want to talk about I mean
there's like a lot to you know we could
talk about we've spent a lot of years in
school I've spent four years in college
and a lot of people who watch this I'm
sure still go to college so could apply
could apply good what was to give me
alright let's start at the beginning
yeah okay when you like applied for
schools and everything like that what
was what was your gimmick what were what
were you looking for what was your life
about when I was applying for schools I
was it was all baseball I was trying to
aim for schools that I would have a good
chance at getting innings like I wasn't
just gonna be on the team I was gonna
get to play right but at the same time I
want to go to good you know competitive
schools the research community college
that I was thinking about and then there
was Chapman
there was also University of Kansas but
it wasn't didn't really work
I had a couple Scouts but nothing panned
out so I went to Chapman because I had
spoken with the coach and he seemed to
have some interest in catchers and I
just thought I could I could I thought I
could you know be so you had no academic
goals at all that's not true I mean I
pick Chapman over a minor academic goal
well here's what happened at all well
here's what happened here's what
happened I was planning on going to
community college because I was gonna
sacrifice good academics for a couple
years of playing baseball right but then
I got into Chapman which was a little
bit of a reach school for me it wasn't
so a reachable but it was kind of Ricci
because well people that are watching
that don't know what Chapman University
is it will you explain it it's a it's a
little it's expensive it's a private
school it's but it's got a good
reputation for its programs and it has
like a lot of good like film arts like
that sort of thing it's a very like I
mean you don't want to say prestigious
but it's up there you know it's like
they people yes so those of you that
aren't in the state of California or
I've never been to the state of
California it's what you would picture a
California school is like yes it's like
people are studying film and television
they're studying in the entertainment
industry it's a good-looking campus it's
a good-looking campus it's you know sort
of exclusive that sort of vibe and it's
expensive it's expensive so yeah like I
said Chapman accepted me which was uh it
was I had been on put on the hold on
waiting list and then after that I got
accepted so I had already basically made
like moving plans for the Community
College everything was already sick Wow
the Chapman and I was like I had to tell
my best friend Andrew I was like cuz
we're gonna room together oh dude I'm so
sorry but I got that guy huh oh my god
it's alright you guys it's still friends
yeah we're still friends you know Andrew
he's come over and hung out but yeah
that's what happened he's walls - he
plays beautiful he plays now at Cal
State LA um he's a baller oh you know
he's [ __ ] good cal state la's no joke
right um so yeah to answer your question
I did have like you know when I chose
Chapman obviously academics were thought
because I could have still gone to the
Community College right but I went to
Chapman huh so yeah what about you well
what were you when you were applying in
high school what was I mean I mean you
you went from Rochester to Boston well
you went to school
was that the goal what did you want to
go into Boston or do you kind of that
happened it was hi marble I see you
honey he's looking at me so mom what are
you doing um when I was in high school
my high school well I think when I
graduated was ranked number 11 best high
school in the nation at one point it was
like number three like basically
everyone goes to really really amazing
colleges there's about 1,400 kids in the
high school 9th through 12th grade and
yeah everyone just is way [ __ ] smart
and I was sort of regular and my only
goal was to just leave the state of New
York so I made a compromise with my mom
and she was like you're just going to
apply you have to apply to one state
school just so that's like you're back
up back up back up back up and I think
it was also just because you know when
you go in state you save a lot of money
just as an option to me so I applied to
six schools the five of them were out of
state two of them were in Massachusetts
two of them were in Maryland one was in
Rhode Island and then I applied to
[ __ ] a Sunni School in New York that
I was like yeah [ __ ] you guys and I'm
totally just throwing that one away
I'm not going thanks for reading my
application but [ __ ] you and uh when I
brought my list into my school counselor
he sort of like laughed at me and was
like these are all safe schools I'm like
yeah I don't [ __ ] care I don't care I
really don't [ __ ] care like I just
want to go to a big city that's it
that's all I want and like who are you
to tell me that I can't go I want to go
that's that's all I got
he's like all right good and I sort of
half believed him and then I got
accepted into all six schools oh [ __ ]
yeah and I was like yeah [ __ ] yeah
choice is how you do it I see you
choices but for for someone that you
know has always felt very average their
entire life like for example my brother
went to Cornell he's a material science
engineer he finished his PhD when he was
25 and Devin was not even the smartest
kid in our school yeah like by a mile
damn Brighton his [ __ ] work in it it
was it was [ __ ] intense I mean we had
plenty of [ __ ] [ __ ] ass people in
our school too you know what I mean
literally in
I went there sorry I said it um but like
for the majority of our school was sort
of like you know I'm fairly smart but I
felt like a dumbass all the time so I
got into all my schools and I went and
visited them and when as soon as I got
the Suffolk which is where I went in
Boston or like this is it it was like
the most freezing day of all time I was
with my mom like the wind was just like
piercing like this everything was
covered in ice there's a lot of hills
cuz the school is sort of spread out
there's no campus it's just sort of
scattered around the city okay guys we
are like walking up and down the streets
just covered in ice and uh I was like
yeah this dealt my mom's like really
really like are we doing the same thing
right now like this sucks like this
whole day sucks and was like now I'm
going here he's dead and then I became
captain and then I went that's later
down the road we're starting at the
beginning we're starting a debt gaining
Dabu gap beginning so yeah I I went to
Boston that was my gimmick and what you
said there were two schools in
Massachusetts that you got into the
other one Framingham State I'm saying
okay they had a really good teaching
program gotta just cuz that's you know
it's what you do need and they have me
and children are at the same level of
maturity so that's always been an option
for me yeah uh and your mom points out
right now no one was there that's
Suffolk yeah was it different Oh buddy
was there like at least we would like I
went to I almost went to Towson I really
liked house in Maryland um you know we
had a great guide like we got a tour
around the campus like it was nice house
[ __ ] awesome and I was like he has
dump and then we went to Suffolk and I
don't even think anyone showed us around
the campus like like we couldn't there's
nobody in the offices like it's just
nothing and I'm like it doesn't matter
seems cool but I did not have any goals
to play softball and I also was just
trying to go to a liberal liberal arts
school because I had no idea what I
wanted to study so I was really just I
was like making my decision based on the
fact that I wanted to live in a city
because for those of you that have ever
been to Rochester and know what
Rochester New York is it kind of makes
you pitch for a city after a while
that's interesting I didn't know that
you had you know no softball in mind
when you know softball very very
interesting
yep well that's cool I mean it's I mean
I couldn't picture a more opposite time
of visiting college with the orange
beautiful sunny 82 in southern Orange
County the campus is booming with
students like beautiful people
everywhere we're getting a tour really
really snow can we elaborate on that for
a second your school really does have
beautiful people and they're all
outrageously rich and spoiled yes I'm
etiquette yeah
Julian like didn't have a car when he
started there well most people don't
have a car when they go to college like
your junior and senior year maybe you
have a car if you can get one or afford
one these kids at your school would have
two cars I knew a kid who had a BMW and
a Hummer and then the results of his
friend who had a Mustang like I know it
was a challenger I think a Dodge
Challenger and uh he had another I
forget his other it wasn't a great car
but it really shows yeah I mean III
bought my own car when I was a senior in
college anyway therefore that and I had
ridden my bike everywhere before yeah
like I've got I read my bike so much I
was like you know I need to invest
I bought a road bike on eBay and I would
ride to school which is like 2 and 1/2
miles I'd ride back and whatever a
couple times a day and on the weekends I
would have to come to LA to work at amp
radio so I would ride to the train
station take my bike on the train switch
to like forth you know trains and then
I'd ride from the train station in LA a
total of what like I mean if you were if
you're on the train time and then also
for you to get to amp radio and back
yeah so if you're calculating from my
door in Anaheim to amp radio it's
probably like two and a half hours when
really if you take a car it's about 50
minutes right but I'm saying how many
miles did you bike during that ya know
that's a question well it's like to my
it was two miles from my house and
orange to the train station decision and
then it was seven miles from the train
station 2 amp radios or to your half my
house and then I would go for my house
house because I'd go how far is it from
your house amp radio like seven miles a
train stations right near it's
ridiculous but I got used to and I
honestly loved it like for those of you
who have ridden bikes for like commutes
you find it to be a little bit
therapeutic because not only you
have to worry about you know whether you
carpool or anything like that but you
have no worries about traffic ever you
always just fly down the street and also
you know something about getting up in
the morning or wherever you're going you
know whatever time of day and getting on
your bike it's just it's a good feeling
like for those of you have written a
road bike it's a really good feeling it
gets you you know you a little bit you
forward from writing but I got my car
senior year and then I was just like a
full-on adult like I could go places and
you know it was really good yeah but
back to the kids having two cars that's
that's why I want to talk about this yes
yeah that's that's a type of person that
we're talking about goes for traveling
unfortunately Chapman is populated by a
lot of rich snobby kids who have because
they grew up in Orange County and
surrounding oh yeah or a similar area
wherever they are it's like a different
state they grew up in that lifestyle
right yeah I mean right so it's the
culture of your school yeah I had the
pleasure of visiting Chapman don't get
me wrong I like Chapman but uh you
certainly get that vibe when you're
there this like yeah we're rich and
better than you mo [ __ ] yeah uh yeah
nice anyways straight point take us
through your freshman year Julian well I
think the whole year not that eventful
but but my freshman year was um will you
stay in the dorms freshman year right
like I'm sure you know every other
college so I had two roommates at first
you know there's this thing called I'm
sure everyone has a similar thing
orientation week so basically school
hasn't started yet you have a whole week
Monday through Friday and the weekend of
basically like events thrown by the
school whether it's like parties or like
meet-and-greet type things right
to get you socializing with your new
classmates but your basic I mean it
boils down to you being drunk for seven
days in a row like you get there you get
a school and you like you're best
friends with your roommate because
that's all you really have you don't
know anyone and everyone's in the same
boat so when I think of freshman year
honestly it's sad but I mean that's a
little bit the high point you know I
mean like I had a great I think that I
had a great time I met some cool people
stay in the dorms I like the dorms but
as the year went on
got hurt couldn't play baseball so that
was really foreign to me I had to like
sit in my room and not do things that
dreams crushed yeah I know this would
you hurt I hurt my back I fractured a
spine I had this thing called an
infectious manufactured us bub a
vertebrae I was called spondylolysis for
those you can look it up it's basically
when there's a crack in your vertebrae
and it basically equates for you to have
have to do a lot of rehab in therapy up
to the surrounding muscles cuz uh
basically any movement when that first
happens is twisting twisting yeah the
twisting is what really causes pain and
so I was just get that get throw
everything in baseball yeah I couldn't
do anything baseball I guess you could
walk if you got a walk yeah
designated Walker I couldn't do much
there was one point where I was like I
couldn't like walk and I was taking
vicodin and that wasn't even helping and
it was just [ __ ] horrible
but enough about my sob story I wasn't
playing baseball freshman year so a lot
of my freshman year was filled up with
like kind of alone time in my dorm room
and kind of not really having that much
friends that many friends I just didn't
have I wasn't in my comfort zone I
didn't have my teammates that I normally
had it was just kind of a weird time but
you know I lived in the dorm I like
living in the dorm I liked biking around
campus I had a longboard I rode that um
you know it's just like you kind of find
what's cool about freshmen here is you
really just kind of learned for the
first time in your life to find your way
you know in high school you're
independent but you don't really like do
everything yourself you don't have to be
your own boss but yeah that's what I
remember most no what about you um I
also lived in a dorm I think because I
came from out of state and I didn't
really realize when because you already
know my criteria of picking my college I
didn't really realize how big of a
commuter school it was so in order to
get student housing there's only two
dorms one's like 11 floors and one was
like 15 floors or something but that's
it for everybody so you're you're only
guaranteed housing one year maybe and
then usually the only way to get a
second year of housing is if you're
really an RA or something like that
because they kick everybody the [ __ ] out
and then you because it's a huge
commuters
which is what I didn't realize so many
people come in from the suburbs of
Boston but I lived in the dorm my
freshman year and I lived in just like a
you know with one other person but I was
right next door to a like seven or nine
girls suite which I was quickly dubbed
Kimmy Gibbler because I was always
knocking on that do you get that
reference and I don't keep on its you
ever seen the show full house I've seen
a show for okay so Kimmy Gibbler is the
girl that lives next door that's always
constantly coming in there and I'm just
[ __ ] being ridiculous oh yes oh my
girl with the
yeah yeah so I was kidding yeah yeah hey
keep it giblet come on they're like oh
yeah I'm gonna come over right now and
it's just cuz I live next door whatever
anyways um so the girl that I roomed
with originally was another girl I you
know we have the weird awkward phone
call like hey I'm Jenna it's nice to me
too because this was a Facebook at the
time was still only for Ivy League
schools so we didn't have Facebook
there's no real way to find a person
unless you had their name and phone
number okay or they had a myspace that
you could creep on but the girl just
bought up never coming she was from
Buffalo I was like we're gonna hit it
off just a couple of whales from upstate
New York hanging out in Boston yeah a
great time Rochelle she well I think she
had financial problems and couldn't come
Suffolk public or private it's a private
school private school I think [ __ ] I
no no no like well you can look it up if
you want to know specifically look it's
not a [ __ ] state school I don't know
okay I'm sorry I didn't mean gell-mann
yeah so I you know two weeks before I
move into my dorm I find that I'm living
with this girl I don't want to say her
name but she had two first names
and I was sort of already pissed because
I established this over the phone
rapport with my new roommate who's no
longer coming and I'm like this girl is
too first [ __ ] names who the [ __ ] is
to first [ __ ] names like her name was
like I'll give you an example like Jane
Betty
got it okay Jamie Angela more like with
the actual [ __ ] so I met this girl and
she was really really cool but as we're
moving our stuff in her like 35 year old
boyfriend is also moving her stuff in
and I thought it was her dad because she
had no family cuz she was a commuter she
lived around Boston dad yeah so she was
from the suburbs and she's moving in
with her like 35 year old boyfriend I
was her dad and uh she's like oh no this
is my this is my boyfriend I'm like wait
what like he's literally bald he's bald
and you know obviously in the dorms
weren't allowed to have any alcohol not
only I was 17 when I moved in she was
like 18 like he could be a senator sorry
what he's old enough to be a senator
probably yeah 35 him um and so this I
was like oh my god like this girl first
of all she had hair down to her ass like
she looked like Zelda you know all right
yeah so um our friends started calling
her boyfriend Linc just because okay um
and I was sort of really nervous like oh
my god this girl has like this creepy
old boyfriend like is he gonna be here
all the time like what the [ __ ] no he
wasn't
you want to know why because that old
ass [ __ ] thought it was such a
good idea to smuggle in bottles of
liquor while they're moving in on moving
day thinking that they're never gonna
find it since everyone's moving in so
much stuff
no no they found it and he got banned
for the entire first year from that's
unheard of the dorms so she would leave
Wednesday night and come back Monday
morning how do you have a schedule like
that freshmen him to Malin jeez I didn't
think that's crazy so she would leave
you had the door multis would leave and
go stay in wherever link lived and so I
pretty much had the room to myself which
was fantastic and then I was also next
door to Kinney gibla but my door was
always open and I lived with some very
interesting people in the dorm and one
of which used to love to get drunk and
come into my room open it in the middle
of the night make himself a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich and then leave
that's that's a like that style
right there that's good she wants my
little mini fridge with both so my Brett
I need that so hungry yeah that's you
know when I was a freshman I you know I
stopped hanging out too much with my
roommates and the people in my floor I
really got along with right we had some
good times cuz you know what whatever
you're doing at the end of the night
you're all like in the same area so yeah
just kind of you know [ __ ] around each
other's rooms yeah but uh yeah that's
funny yeah we did a lot of [ __ ] but I
definitely didn't start making friends
with people until after the first
semester at first semester was kind of
rough cuz I was kind of lonely and my
18th birthday was like right in
September didn't know a single human
being yeah there and didn't yeah I
didn't have really 18th birthday there
just laid in my bed and like cried about
it
um and I did want to transfer it for a
hot second but I didn't yeah suck it out
I just started playing softball I was
like I was good to go
that's awesome that you found softball
in it you know make your time a little
better yeah well the only reason I
played softball is because I emailed the
coach and was like hey I'm sort of a
mediocre player are you guys looking for
players and she called me at my house
and was like we'd love to have you like
just come try out as a walk-on and I
made it as a walk-on then yes
two years later what were you two years
later I was a captain as a junior
captain okay it's all bad no it is a big
deal your [ __ ] captain it was pretty
dope junior yeah I mean I've heard of
captain's uh you know from walk-ons and
stuff but I haven't heard of a junior
captain at least from people I know
that's really impressive it was pretty
dope school and what position did you
play uh I pitched I played outfield
mostly and I was a lefty slapper so
basically your I'd like the highest
batting average good no not really
what is it the explain slap okay
slapping you basically are running out
of the box right and like you leading
you're not running out of the box per se
the idea is to start at the very very
very back of the box you're hitting
left-handed okay you are taking several
steps down the first base line but you
can't make contact with the ball outside
of the box so your feet have to be in
the box when you hit I think at least
one so it's kind of like a drag bunt
yeah except you're hitting except you're
hitting so baseball there's a drag bunt
and
correct okay but the idea behind a slap
hitter is that you're supposed to have
your fastest players become slappers
it's supposed to be a hard chop to the
shortstop third baseman second baseman
for a while
prep no well a chopped yes like a ground
ball that hits hard it's not yeah it's
not a pop flies no bounces and it goes
right so the idea is to get someone whit
white look I was confused because you
said yeah it's in the air for a while no
no no no grasshopper I know what that
means okay um yeah anyways the idea is
to chop something hard down the
left-field line so that you can beat out
even just a ground ball from the
shortstop or the third baseman because
you're already considerably closer to
first base cuz you're lefty and you're
leaning out of the box and you're
already running yeah generally me so
anyone that's like a relatively good
hitter but is very fast
you want to turn them into a slapper and
you were fast then right yeah I di
ideal ideally you would have to slap
hitters that would follow each other so
the misconception for a lot of people in
baseball is that you have the meat of
your lineup sort of like one through
four or five but in softball it's not
uncommon to have slap hitters heading in
the one and nine spot yeah because they
follow each other so when when the you
know order rotates your 9 hitter is
basically you know essentially your
number one hitter got it not here's oh
you know I'm like yeah a ninth is dope
walking idiot the nine hitter is also
referred to as the second leadoff hitter
right yeah I mean in baseball also right
so yeah that's interesting well I wasn't
good enough to be number one no but I
was good enough looser 9 he's feeling
there I hit nine a lot of my career
because I was a kid oh it makes a huge
difference but that was I'm not even
sure but I'm you know I still don't know
the answer to this but I'm pretty sure
the reason at least in high school and
college
the catcher hits 9 is because he needs
more time to get his gear back so like
if you don't want to leading off and
then he's on base and he has to run no
that's not the reason but um yeah yeah
you either had them one in 9 or 1 & 2 or
if there were some seasons where we had
three slappers so we'd have 1 2 & 9 oh
that's cool
oh yes [ __ ]
snappers cat what what the only problem
was that I had really really terrible
form so I would often just drill the
[ __ ] ball into right field I'm gonna
hit that's how I hit a home run into
right field because there's a thing in
slaw on top wall called slap defense
which is they know that your child they
make a shift right can I finish I'm
sorry I just want to finish okay so
there's a thing in softball called slap
defense where they know that you're
trying to chop it to the left side so
they move the infield in considerably in
case you hit it into a gap you have a
closed infielder to catch that because
the idea is that you're not swinging for
the fences you're just trying to chop
something hard through a hole or add an
infielder that's too difficult for them
to field in time so when there's a slap
defense if you have really shitty form
and just give zero [ __ ] it's very easy
to hit it over the right fielders head
because you just [ __ ] lay into it and
because you're heading lefty that's just
like [ __ ] homerun territory there's a
fencer just kids going on on our home
field there was no fence overwrite
fields there was in left field where did
you hit it at home yeah man yeah I feel
yeah um but the problem with that
strategy is that once you do it one time
they stopped doing slap defense on you
do you know what I mean so but then
wouldn't it mean that you can slap
successfully because they're not playing
the right slaps you're correct that's
awesome but you can't hit awesome
homeruns how many home runs did you hit
just one okay well as a let the slapper
I just hit one home run and still it was
like the funniest thing ever
my dad was actually at that game which
was awesome like we always said whoever
hit a home run as a slapper you got like
an iron Lotus like in blades of glory
like you know I'm Jack yes I know right
huh so you're always like oh man man
ahead and iron Lotus this game and just
[ __ ] feel it and no one on my team
had ever done it and I did it and I was
so like ice crossed home plate and I
started [ __ ] pissing my pants
laughing like I had a tire Lotus it's
possible it's [ __ ] possible you are a
natural right hand
right yeah okay but I'm lefty in a lot
of things you're ambidextrous person but
you hit ready would just start with and
softballs a child and then you switched
over to slap my question did you ever
get like to the point where you were so
comfortable lefty because of all the
at-bats you got and then you just
started hitting lefty no no no I that
wasn't the goal I mean there are
definitely people that you know the
coach would be like swing away either
side but I'm I'm not one of those people
you had you were better right II like
hitting power wise yeah I don't have
that home runs ready not that I remember
I really didn't get a ton of a bats my
freshman year okay um and then I think
sophomore years when I turned around
yeah so you know you don't really get a
whole bunch of opportunities to be
crushing yeah you know yeah you know
actually bombs uh uh I forgot what I was
gonna say whatever well that's that's
what I mean I think why I ask that
question is because um well I I was a
switch hitter mm-hmm and in baseball uh
one benefit that both switch hitters and
left-handed hitters have is you get to
hit a lot from that side of the plate
because the only reason you hit lefty
for most people is to go against the
righty pitcher for whatever pitcher side
they throw you go to the opposite and
obviously it's dominated by right-handed
pitchers everywhere so you know I
switched over to switch hitting my
sophomore year of high school and I got
so many at-bats where I felt like I'm
like I got every time I got to the right
side of the box like ah right we're you
know I mean so I just sometimes I would
just go lefty on lefty and I would just
I just felt so comfortable because of
all the high pass yeah yeah well what I
figured out was that I'm right I
dominant which is like I forget how you
do it but it's just really easy to like
[ __ ] I can't remember the test if you
remember your eye and then open I don't
know it's something like that and if it
moves then that eye is dominant it well
no just come on um but my right eye sees
the ball so much better so once I turned
around to the left side I felt like I
can see the ball so much better because
my eye my right eye was so much closer
and was looking that's your leader right
because when you're
you're heading righty you're looking
with your left eye and like ah that's my
walkie aye that's crazy
it not only looks wonky it is monkey ah
so I made that that's crazy as soon as I
turned around I felt like I could see
everything happening on the ball yeah
that's really cool man yeah God when you
see the ball and it looks like a beach
ball and you're just like crashing it's
such a good fly [ __ ] yeah you're going
bye-bye
bye ball bye boy get legs bouquet like
Howie you're a freak yeah so I played
softball for years what did you do after
you were done playing baseball uh I hurt
myself freshman year rehabbed my whole
freshman year summer after the freshman
year and I came back sophomore year
thinking I was like good to go and it
turns out I rehabbed my back I lifted
weights I got back in shape but the
twisting I mean it still hurt my eye
like my back I couldn't do it so I had
this point where I was like I was
catching a lot of bullpens I was mixing
myself in the practices I was duo doing
okay in the practices I would hit the
ball pretty hard but at a certain point
like I couldn't take enough BP I
couldn't throw enough long toss like I
couldn't without pain so I had to just
train to the point where I wasn't
getting better and I wasn't competing so
I took myself out it was the hardest
decision I've ever had to make
and I quit I told the coach I had to
hang it up but um yeah I was stopped
playing baseball and then a little while
after that I found Brazilian jiu-jitsu
which was great for me great for me I've
loved it still love it I haven't been
back but I intend to keep training you
know as I you know as my life goes on
but it was great because it was it was a
competitive outlet for me after I had
lost the only competitive outlet I have
ever known
weightlifting - yeah weightlifting came
along a little later
um weightlifting came along my senior
year which is my you know basically like
a year ago I started you know not a year
like you know eight months ago nine
months ago I started taking
weightlifting seriously and I just
compete me but yeah there's that
competitive thing in me I just can't I
can't ignore it so jiu-jitsu was great
off the rebound of losing baseball and
then weightlifting
yeah definitely what else did you do in
college though tell me about your
college um I did a radio program at
school our campus had a radio program
you basically created your own show had
an hour on air and do whatever you want
broadcasted it like the Student Union
and you can listen online I love that I
did an MMA radio show which is cool like
interviewed fighters and stuff mm-hmm
I don't think I don't oh well when I
stopped being able to afford jujitsu
like membership me and my friend snuck
into the gym where there was like pads
and stuff and we just rolled her half
and and yeah I kind of lost my thought
but yeah rolled around on the pads yeah
we just we were like we stopped going to
class because it was too expensive
jiu-jitsu class not class class and we
just decided to get like our compression
shorts hot [ __ ] roll around all
sweaty a couple of bros rolling around
on the and the spare mats and the gym at
night that sounded really weird but yeah
and then I got into the television
broadcast journalism program and that's
kind of what took up all my time I did
write for the school paper for like a
year and a half yeah I was a sports
editor for yeah you had [ __ ] okay I
liked your run down but I want the
[ __ ] drama tell me about the drama
tell me about the [ __ ] your school
with that news and they [ __ ] sidled
you and they're being such dicks and
your paper desi really want to eat you
but yeah you don't need to go into names
or anything you don't have to do any of
that but like just be real for a second
like some some parts of your college
experience that I got to witness where
like a disservice to you was a human
being and I have the same experiences
with a lot of things happened to me in
college but like it it wasn't all great
some who was weird I never said it was
all great yeah my college career was not
all great was a lot of learning
experiences which were hard one of which
was the Chapman news program which I
have a lot of good things to say about
and I'm not going to just sit here and
talk trash about it but there were
certain times where I felt like I was
really investing my time it was
basically a news
channel that the students ran it was all
run by students producing you know
talent interviews everything everything
every single week there was one live
newscast that was done all by the
students and I felt for a while that I
had worked my way up and I was really
really sucked like I really want to do
this reporter thing I had like I [ __ ]
loved being on camera with a mic I felt
confident I was just into it and for a
while I had put a lot of effort into my
stories and just kind of bettering
myself and it became really clear to me
really fast that some of the people who
were in fact younger than me but who
were influential in the program decided
that you know their whole mo was
themselves they didn't care about all
the young people or about everyone else
who was participating in making this
even a thing it became a really selfish
attitude that I started to recognize and
I had a couple incidents where you know
people said things and I just didn't
like it and it just became it really
alienated me like for I don't know if
any of you had like her you have had
something in your life that you like and
then the people involved in that thing
just alienate you from it and I'm like
no one's like that with you I wanted you
to mention it because I think it's
really important that people you know
when looking back on your college
experience that people address the good
with the bad junior ya know I appreciate
you asking that cuz I wasn't going to
just bring up negative times but it's
important to talk about right because I
think at some point everyone at least in
college can relate to feeling sort of
run down by politics of things cheering
yes it's just garbage doesn't matter
what you're involved in if it's like a
sorority if it's a sports team if it's a
club if it's a [ __ ] whatever you know
you feel it in high school and you feel
like when you get to college or you know
at least people are gonna be a little
bit more adult but that's not really the
case somebody at some point within their
major within [ __ ] whatever yeah they
start to feel the politics of things and
some of its really [ __ ] up and wrong I
mean for example like uh in the news
that letter by that sorority girl you
know basically bullying all of the
sorority sisters or the [ __ ] you call
them I don't [ __ ] know but like you
know just being an [ __ ] and
and when you're in that world that's one
of the most important things you in your
life right you've invested so much time
into this sorority or news or sport or
whatever and to feel like so run down by
the people above you or around you if
you're outnumbered by a coach by a
mentor teacher of whatever it's really
[ __ ] up and the whole system is kind
of [ __ ] up in that you know what I
mean it only gets more [ __ ] up in life
there's plenty of politics and that but
like you're sort of in a safe place that
you're paying for and you can't even get
[ __ ] just regular ass people with
regular as treatments unfortunate but
like you said I mean it's a good
precursor to real life because that
should exist in real life
and it just sucks because you think
because they're your peers you know
they're you're going to have a time in
college where you can all learn together
and you can all kind of be on a team but
in certain situations the politics just
get so overwhelming and strong egos
there's egos I mean there's like there's
come there's it boils down to egos
really I mean especially when you're
talking about the Chapman news thing
when you're on camera and there's people
who are trying to get jobs out of the
school from being on camera it's all you
guys I mean you're like you know you can
you can have an ego and be successful
and be good at something while also
being a team player and learning how to
do it right but it's also just being
egotistical it this something I've
always felt is a real thing like I'm not
great at business but I feel like you
can get anywhere that you want to go in
life while still being good person you
don't have to be cutthroat you don't
have to be a [ __ ] shark I feel like
you can get whatever you want in life if
you're a good person yes yes you are you
look at you look there's plenty of
examples of [ __ ] who are successful
but then you look at like the Joe Rogan
or the rockers people like that who are
just good [ __ ] people you know what I
mean the great people and they've
achieved everything that you can imagine
and it's possible I think that's a great
thing to say that you can do anything
and everything that you desire and want
to do and I hope to do while being a
good person and what's unfortunate about
these organizations and college is that
like they're being rewarded for that
behavior yeah you know what life people
are rewarded for that behavior yeah the
worst part is that I felt like the the
staff because you know it was run by
students but the staff was
posed to have some sort of governing
power backing my problem was that like
the staff just kind of like saw this
happening was just like I'm gonna back
away yeah and then suddenly it was just
like its own monster you know I mean no
one could regulate it if you were on a
[ __ ] realistic then you couldn't change
there was no it's just it was what it
was and you know I could see I could go
on all day but the bottom line is you
have these experiences and I'm really
happy you brought this up but you have
these experiences and they start in my
opinion for me like in college where you
know you things are unfair and people
aren't nice and they're not good and
they're not helpful or or decent at all
and you kind of just have to either deal
with you know learning how to exist
coexist with those people and thrive or
you have to learn how to say goodbye to
something and move out because it's not
your you have to realize when it's not
your turf and when it's not your battle
to pick or something you even want to do
anymore right you know I really you know
I I had this like six months period
where I was like I was doing these live
shots where I was interviewing people or
I was talking to the camera alive and I
loved the live thing cuz it was just
like you have to nail and it was all
pressure and I loved it
well do it live live what does that mean
to play us out exactly exactly
but I like it I've never had something
go from like we appear like I've
excitement and passion and everything to
just kind of flatlining and it is what
it is I'm not sad about it you know I
still love interviewing I love doing
this podcast if there was ever an
opportunity in my future where I could
interview people regularly or what I'm
really good at it
it's kind of a joke it's kind of
disgusting I don't know what like yeah
it's it's sort of mind-blowing because
I'm not like that like I can't think of
my toes that fast I think on my heels
and I got your high heels oh I get there
I get to the point in the question
eventually but not without some [ __ ]
in the middle but the way that you
interview people is sort of such it's
like an art and a science that is
absolutely 100% a skill that you have
honed doing I mean so it's sad to me
that these people sort of put such a
negative air around something that you
really enjoy doing you're really good at
doing to the point where you don't want
to do it anymore
like I don't know I just feel like you
can use that ability to talk to people
and really think on your toes not in a
dumbass way like most of the people you
see working interviewing people on red
carpets are [ __ ] on the news like
you're just what's your [ __ ] deal
what is your deal yeah can you [ __ ]
not suck right now yeah well you're
gonna be able to use it in another arena
I believe that I'd like wholeheartedly
and I appreciate you saying that because
you know I discovered how much I liked
it and then I just did it all the time
so what I think I mean like as much as
it kind of just capped me doing the
whole you know cookie cut a reporter
thing I just feel like now I can take my
talents or whatever I want to call it my
my passion for talking and interviewing
and everything elsewhere and it doesn't
have to be in a box this time and I'm
excited about that and that's why I'm
really really jacked about this podcast
because it's an opportunity for us to
just kind of get on the platform of
talking hey you know whatever you want
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not a box I'm
not in their box right as much as I
could have been happier yeah yeah that's
what was so funny to me is that we still
[ __ ] joke about that so god you don't
want that job where you have to like
speak the way that they ask you to speak
about everything that's going on i'm
cecilia Vega
[ __ ] that God [ __ ] her [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah anyways you you absolutely need a
certain voice you need a certain like
way about you in order to be successful
in that field which is just [ __ ] have
you been watching the news at all
recently
it feels so updated and the almost is
there like change their format it's just
so weird like when they're playing viral
videos on the news I'm like can you stop
they're talking about a like you're
talking in the past it's it's pathetic
no they're like we're breaking this
right now yeah but no but there's a
manner of which they're talking sounds
so outdated yes like well I just don't
understand why they can't just speak
like regular humans because it's an
old-school institution the news it's
like you have to abide and see these all
these old people watching at home so
they think that they can't
yeah what an eerie night for the
elephant
he had lost one meter my dad is a
tailless puns like horrible voiceover
I'm like but that's with it okay see
hearing like talking about this makes me
so excited because now you know I exist
on the Internet and I love the Internet
Jenna showed me the Internet and to the
capacity well she showed me the capacity
that you been a predator I've been a
redditor I've been a wreck no but I'm
saying like you know you showed me the
other side and now I'm getting a little
taste of that you know people are
starting to follow me and everything
like that but it's it's very interesting
because it's exciting and it's a new
thing and I like it and it's a lot about
you know doing whatever the [ __ ] you
want and I feel like I can take whatever
I had you know developed and liked about
reporting and talking and interviewing
on camera into who the [ __ ] knows into
the vast ambiguous future that exists
wherever well at least in my opinion I
feel like I do Internet II stuff because
I started off just being like oh I have
like one or two people that I would want
to show this to but since there's been
you know other people that are
interested in it I make things for me I
do what I want to do yeah and if people
want to watch it that's fine if you
don't want to watch it that's fine like
I'm still gonna do it joining mean so if
you like doing things like this or
talking to people or interviewing people
like just give zero [ __ ] and just go do
it then if anybody wants to pay
attention to it they can if they don't
then [ __ ] off I'll see you at lunch yes
God story Jenna Oh words to live by you
have something you want to do [ __ ] do
it
find a way to do and if not see you at
lunch see how much give me your money
Pizza Nuggets sorry uh no yeah yeah
and um you know for those of you who it
was so crazy i what am i weight lifting
meet this girl came up to us and was
like hey I recognize YouTube from
Jenna's play hi can't get a picture
remember her and then she said to me um
I loved your interview with Chris Biel
how did you even get to meet which was
the craziest thing to me because there's
an interview on my youtube channel of me
and an MMA fighter which I actually did
for one of my classes at Chapman but I
only picked that interview because I
wanted
I was going to do [ __ ] councilmen in
Anaheim but for her to actually have
known and asked me about it is like the
craziest thing in the whole world and
it's really really cool and it makes me
happy and makes me so excited to do it
yes you're so passionate about Chris
peel and many other MMA fighters like
why wouldn't other people be interested
in it and the fact that you're
interviewing them in a way that's not
[ __ ] yeah don't I mean huh you're
asking him legitimate questions and not
just like this stupid like so how are
you preparing for your next fight yeah
[ __ ] Oh [ __ ] care I don't care yeah
there's nothing better to hear after an
interview than someone telling me like
that was not the interview I expected or
I've never been asked questions like you
know I mean like you're you're getting
time from them why are you gonna waste
it right like make it worth their while
let them enjoy the conversation talk to
them don't even worry about the [ __ ]
camera just chill out and have a
conversation like you you like you
people who watch Jenna's YouTube channel
and mine and everyone else isn't you
know on YouTube you watch them because
they're relatable and you feel like you
can get a sense of who they are and
they're being them to a set you know to
a certain extent and when people do
interviews and they're just like you
can't [ __ ] relate to that you don't
know what that is it makes you want to
throw it yeah so it's like when I have a
conversation with someone regardless of
whether is a camera there on your mic
top it's a conversation you know I mean
you're going to make them happy you're
gonna make the viewer like more
enlightened as to who this person is and
why you're talking to them I don't know
man well the only thing I have to say
about that from an interviewee
perspective for most of these people
their jobs their lives their livelihood
is beyond them like if you're talking
about an actor like there's so many
people working behind them to make sure
that you [ __ ] you keep your mouth
shut you say we're supposed to say you
say positive things about the project
the movie you know because we cannot
afford for you to just go off the rails
and just do a bunch of [ __ ] damage in
your control yeah so you're sort of
mastered by people whose livelihood and
lives also depend on you not losing your
[ __ ] mind
underneath so you can't really be a
loose cannon and continue to have a job
which is like terrible to me which is
why I suck at mainstream media
because I just don't want to play the
game during play the game like all I
have is my voice why would I want it to
be taken away from me and just have
everything that I tweet and say and do
just be like some promotional garbage
you can abide by some set of rules and
my brain my voice my everything that I
had to say is priceless yeah and it's
not worth selling my soul to be
successful in any arena and then have
that taken away from me because it's a
business move dude I mean absolutely you
can't put a price on being honest and
who you are like it's just but many
people do so I feel like there's many
MMA fighters that you know they pump up
the fights they do that sort of thing
but they can't really just speak their
mind for example about the UFC as a
whole about a white horse an employer
yeah that's what I'm saying
no yeah you can't and if anyone goes off
the rails
you're just you're cut off you're out
you can't have that can't have you
spewing off at the mouth about things
that people aren't supposed to know
because that hurts the business yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying is that you
sacrifice sort of your freedom of speech
and your brain in your mind to be
successful at a certain level yeah yeah
because then people need to make sure
that you're not mad you don't have a
message you're set free that's that's
what you are you're an investment at
that point you I mean you're a talent
investment yeah which i think is [ __ ]
garbage for most situations yeah so many
people they're willing to play the game
and they like that junuh means yeah
they're happy and they're paid and
they're [ __ ] taking care of their
families and all that yeah boots don't
think I have it in me I mean I think
like yes there's a lot a lot
overwhelming majority amount of
situations where someone's hired like a
talent and they no longer can say
anything they want they can't do what
they're you know they want to they have
to listen to their producer or whoever
but I feel like the you know the point
where I draw the line is when I have a
strong feeling about something and I
want to voice my honest opinion on
something I am passionate about and I
can't know that's the point I feel like
that's the point where I can't be put in
a box like I won't agree to anything you
know anything like it isn't something
that you learn in college though you
have all these opinions all these
thoughts and something that you know
wrong but you know if you speak out
you're outnumbered in your out power and
you're wrong in the industry you're not
really
you are the outsider journey yeah so
it's it's a terrible thing it's real
life but to me it's more important to be
that outsider and have that opinion and
have those feelings than to be the
jackass on the inside that's drinking
the kool-aid huh Jeremy absolutely I'm
not drinking that kool-aid I would want
I would align myself somewhere to that
yeah watching it do it I'm just bad I
don't have it in me yeah how you come on
flood like that my headphones popped out
oh oh Mecca you've you Mew Mew Mew
praise praise me that's a good thanks oh
yeah I got so just the whole College
thing I mean uh you just earned your a
piece of paper yeah got the piece but
you got your very expensive piece of
paper looking back on it uh as a whole
is college worth it to you
yes absolutely I think a lot of a lot of
college isn't goods and glamour and
super fun and easy or convenient but at
the end of the day it's something that I
feel like I wouldn't be where I am today
if I didn't go through I wouldn't be the
person I am what the experience I've had
with the people I've met the opinions
I've made you know just to get the
formulation of who I exist as in this
moment I wouldn't have had without
college I wouldn't be here without
college and that's for better or for
worse you know I mean it's where I am
now
for better for worse and one other thing
I think College says something about you
and it says you know this person can
follow through on something that isn't
necessarily the easiest thing to fall
through mm-hmm so I would absolutely say
yes College it was a good overall thing
I'm happy I did it yeah because I mean
there's a growing opinion that colleges
have turned into a business I heard that
yes and that they're very expensive and
a bachelor's degree even like forget
about an associate's degree or anything
like that a two-year degree a four-year
degree from a very good college no
longer guarantees you
an entry-level job yes so it's sort of
like the argument can be made is college
worth it and I'm in the same boat as you
that I think it's very much worth it
very very very much worth it because it
proves that you can invest your time and
energy into something that's not
short-sighted George follow through on
you follow through on a four-year plan
I'm sorry when you're [ __ ] 17 years
old four years is a lifetime I mean
absolutely like knowing that you're
gonna be there for for 18 for most
people is 18 yeah well 17 you're lying
like oh man dude that's forever from now
yeah
graduated it already felt like you spent
10 years in high school you know what I
mean at that point you yeah I have a
good snoring um do you want to say hi
but I'm with you and I'm with you that I
think that it's so worth it because I
just feel like you learn how to be who
you are do you mean and no disrespect to
people that choose not to go to college
and choose to start working in the real
world but I just feel like that there's
something about sacrificing you know
your future money happiness jobs like
whatever your personal goals are you put
them all on hold to just better yourself
as a human for four years takes a lot of
willpower it's a financial investment
it's a mental physical emotional
investment and scary is terrifying and
you never know if it's gonna pay off
yeah so I just I got a lot out of it I
learned how to be me yeah which is dope
what is very dope good high five yeah
thanks good pat on the back Thanks
somebody mentioned with college parties
I mean I did not go to a party school we
were both college athletes we I was in
the dorm for one year and then it was
out although I did live in softball how
so were four of us lived there
I've worked weekends since I was like 19
right so I and I eventually worked
weekends as well yeah but is there like
one college party that you could just
tell any story about it all yes uh was
this party close to the door I think
this was my freshman year maybe my
sophomore year you know what I think was
my sophomore year but
went to this party near campus we're
just hanging out as [ __ ] going on
inside on the couches and everything
[ __ ] are you going on outside so I went
outside because it was always so hot
doggery only cow Moos I'm kidding people
go yeah I was outside holding my drink
just being the average college dude just
kind of staying there sipping like just
not just just existing you know I mean
my friends are around I don't really
know how many people that I'm just kind
of hanging out or whatever and uh this
guy comes up to me and he starts you
know doing the thing next to me like the
king of the hill you know they okay yeah
yeah so we're just drinking X to each
other just kind of small talk but I can
tell he's you know pretty drunk slurring
his words and whatnot then he tells me a
hold on one sec bro steps to the left
yes all over he throws up all over the
plants like just throws up like
projectile Shh but no one's looking
we're like in the back like throws up
throws or throws up and I'm like uh what
and I'm like kind of okay J and then he
just [ __ ] stands back next to me and
continues drinking like it didn't just
happen like you didn't just vomit all
over the place but it was the first time
I've ever seen someone rally at that
[ __ ] turnaround speed um so yeah what
were you saying like I couldn't even
believe I was floored
yeah no shame in his game that sticks
out to him he's there to party whether
his body wants to or not his body was
ready that was wild yeah that was great
what about you and he any experiences
stick out well well we had a one party
that was like in my opinion one of the
most memorable parties that we ever had
they were always at our house for some
reason my party I mean like I don't 45
people are there maybe tops and that's
capacity because we lived in a
four-bedroom apartment when it's packed
like that it's a part you know means a
lot of people and you know it was mostly
just like the baseball team in the
softball team and everybody's like
significant others yeah I mean yeah um
but then when I was younger we would go
to the other baseball house in Cambridge
Harbor but which was bigger because they
had two floors of the apartment uh but
one of my favorite parties we threw was
a baseball softball 80s party yeah it
was so unbelievably amazing
like you know hard it is like as an
adult to get everybody to show up in a
costume because at this point you're
sort of like really dude like do we God
do that it's not Halloween like [ __ ] you
yes everybody was so bought into it
the music was 80s everyone was so 80s
like it was just the most incredible
[ __ ] time ever and you know after
that the baseball team tried to throw a
[ __ ] at a Western party Cowboys part
it just didn't work after that
like now we sucked all the fun out but
in terms of like a funny story um sorry
mom
if you haven't heard this story already
it's happened but on Super Bowl Sunday
one year when this other team not the
Patriots not the bills like nobody care
about its playing at all and I
shotgunned 11 beers in like 3 hours and
no one else was drunk and thanks I was
really I was really proud 11 beers in an
afternoon well it was at night cuz at
the Super Bowl airs at night there dude
I mean that's true that's true yeah so
uh yeah everyone was sort of like what
are you doing like dude you're shy
because Super Bowl [ __ ] yeah
and uh I don't know what I was doing
that day I was just I was just on a
mission shotgun beers and I got home to
my apartment and my friend Jill and
Ashley had taken me home like you know
made sure that we walked I walked home I
wasn't really fine you got legs but I
don't remember a lot of it yeah
and uh there's like a three-second video
that exists because we didn't know how
to use my digital camera and
accidentally took a video which we
didn't even know is a feature that the
idiots we could had so many great movies
um of me just like sobbing my eyes out
on the phone with Jackie my best friend
and then there's like a bunch of dope
pictures where I'm just like my hair's
everywhere and I'm like I definitely
like peed my pants at one point there's
like pee on my pants and I'm like hey
and I felt there's a picture before and
I'm standing outside of her door like
where are you it's Jenna and then the
next picture I had fallen all the way
through her closed door like you know if
you close the door how hard it is that's
how hard I fell through it it broke down
okay
and then I woke up the next day and made
it to my 8 a.m. science class he's us
and the kid next to me was also on the
baseball team was like you smell like a
homeless person go home and I was like
oh yeah I forgot that you could miss
classes I've never done that yeah it's
always a weird enlightening experience
when you're like oh I can miss class
but yeah I think I was like a junior or
something when that happened
Julian's story zero Jenna's story one
but I was like normally it was a
sophomore gee I don't remember but I was
like old enough to where you know you
could have skipped tons of classes but I
was like I've literally never done that
yeah that sounds like a great idea
because I'm hammer I need it I was just
gonna go through the day like this yeah
well that that's uh that wins and it's
an epic college story that sounds
magical that first night of the 80s when
everything went well that sounds amazing
oh so magic my friend showed up in
rollerskates that's really cool tastic
that's really cool I like that everyone
was into it that makes a little
difference in the world it never happens
never anything it's magical that's why
it's magical because it never happens
and then Jackie got on this little iPod
and goes this song goes out to my
brother Troy Troy was like nine at the
time my god and she played like some
[ __ ] Metallica or something and there
Jackie dude Jackie your brother's like a
child she's like yeah but if he was here
I've played this song for him I'm like
get it DJ get it go guys that is awesome
yeah for the years before that we also
had one CD that we'd play on repeat at
every party oh yeah shake that and for
me che dad asked me conquer shake their
enemy she but that was like before you
had like it's so no one had an iPod yeah
he's just an eminence they were willing
to leave out at a party cuz everything
got stolen yeah he played one CD over
and over and over and over and over and
over never got old never see especially
when it's that song it was great yeah
come on come on it was a mix that song
was on it got it
okay got it yeah well that's a good song
to have on a mix right cuz it basically
is timeless mm-hmm like Ray Bans
room timeless never goes out of style
but I love that song it's good huh yeah
hey yeah that's me
Oh girls J that okay uh robbers you
wanna say hi mama don't hit your head on
the on the spit guard he hit his head on
there cuz his head so giant is your head
big for your body not because like he's
like is your body small for your head
what a extreme body my boy you have a
body oh yeah I mean there's there's so
much to talk about in college about
college I mean like we could definitely
revisit this topic in someday in the
future yeah yeah because this is just a
lot like I feel like my last couple
years that were [ __ ] [ __ ] got so real
but uh yeah well I'd love to go through
the last couple years sometime you know
because benefit has it's been a great
podcast but you know I like how our
experiences are so different but we can
also find you know relatively you know
relatable ground at least and i think ii
you know that next time we talk about
college it'll be no different but thank
you guys for watching yeah thank you so
much for watching I'm like sweating now
I know we turn off the AC so you guys
don't have to hear that humming so yeah
real hot but it's like really hot and I
should have changed my shirt there's a
bad plan but uh you guys thank you so
much for watching and thank you
subscribe we'll be here every single
Monday with a new podcast Monday and we
if we hadn't by now we should be on I
assume iTunes soon but by the time this
works out we should definitely be on
iTunes and we'll link hit everything on
the description thank you Ustream for
watching and I'll see you guys next week
yeah and sorry for those of you that I
offended by saying [ __ ] she didn't
mean at least what she did me but she
did mean Cecilia Vegas I like to
reiterate that she'll get beach folk
that big shabby [ __ ] up big look that
be no I'm sure she's not a bad person
she's person no she's not she's just she
just had an idiotic moment or ten yeah
or ten or twenty she's up she's not
person I just get it we don't love you
but you know that person yeah we don't
love you but you ain't bad you not the
best we the best we do shaykh ali allah
be the best
oh we're so we just ended the show yeah
we're not done but if you listen to
Sirius XM show I talked to all with a
low poly DJ caliber
we will link TJ colleges graduate all
right did that on one of the podcast
yeah well link is Instagram for you link
it all right you it's there now but
follow us on all the things and we'll
see you next week actually another
podcast
I got a he'll show bad eye